first don't look down you don't need to
you should have done it enough times
that you know where your foot is and you
know where your joe is
and if it's out a few centimeters it's
it's not that big a problem okay if you
if you want tap your foot so you know
you know where it is that's
something you can do please don't look
down
don't bring the shoulder around
edge twist both
wrists knee
open the front foot knee
change the hands knee
strike twist both hands like the
white throttles over your head
the back one turns
and strikes down don't
do this don't make it so it comes
away from
the point where it has to come back
so you've taken that lock
you nail this one
and this one climbs over like that
out over
and strike down the foot at the same
time
[Music]
so that you're working with the from
head to toe
power your mass your mass so make the
foot
have this
loosen the front hand little
open the front foot
look behind you
open the front foot fast
keep this low
back foot now moves step
sweeping round like a
like a cone
don't have it here because your head
will get hit here
i was taught that you should be able to
kiss your jaw
that way you know it's on the outside
yes you can kiss it here but
the aim is to turn your head to it
it stays look for something that's uh
different or something that's repeated
so
i just need to move the camera a little
not the spoil too much but just so you
get the distance
so
if i knew give up a bit then that's a
an age problem
[Music]
have this open when you come back
using the hips not the foot
the hips to move the leg
[Music]
i'm working on a very steep slope here
you possibly can't see that i'm working
on a very steep slope
i have bad knees i have had bad knees
since i was in my 30s osteoarthritis so
if i don't look too good at times
forgive me
i'm working on a slope to show you how
i'm having to
adjust and having to know that the
ground is uneven
and still try and keep the form
[Music]
so
me
say it before or after don't say it
while you're doing it
this this is wrong edge
me me
son she
i can't i've said it before i can't
concentrate on the power
if i'm spending too much time counting
it's like shaking something up in a
bottle
you know if you've got sediment in a
wine bottle and you shake it up it's
going to be
the whole bottle's ruined
pour it slowly before you like you know
slowly
it's
would be forgetting gosh
head to foot nest
the hip picks the leg up
places it
the hip picks the leg up places it
please work hard on your footwork
because uh
you need the footwork to be good and not
just the
you know the arms and how good you look
how fast you can
it's not just how fast you can move your
hands and
arms i personally now
find the footwork more important than
the arms
if the footwork is correct
quite hard to defeat